direction un lieu propice à la flannerie
et à l'émerveillement le château de
Chaumont-sur-Loire et l'édition 2023 du
Festival des Jardins soutien jusqu'au 5
novembre avec cette année une nouvelle
thématique la résilience alors comment
lutter contre les îlots de chaleur
renforcer les plantes de nos jardins et
faire en sorte qu'elle s'épanouissent
dans un contexte de dérèglement
climatique c'est le pari relevé par 25
nouveaux artistes tours d'horizon avec
Faustine Luneau
les premiers visiteurs déambulent d'un
écrin de verdure à l'autre le Festival
International des Jardins a ouvert au
public depuis une dizaine de jours et
déjà la trentaine de créations en met
plein la vue au touriste c'est vraiment
des conceptions incroyables certains
c'est un ravissement ravissement et des
yeux des de tous les sens quoi coup de
coeur presque pour tous donc c'est très
beau il est très
jardin il a été imaginé par l'équipe
dont fait partie Bruno de rosier ce
pépiniériste qui arrive de l'île de Ré a
voulu représenter une franche littorale
submergée par la montée des eaux la
palette végétale que vous avez derrière
ne sont que des plantes à l'offite donc
résistante au sel même s'il y avait une
submersion l'espace qu'on a créé
restauré en place car le thème du
festival cette année le jardin résilient
Louise Quintana a préféré s'inspirer des
jardins vivriers ancestraux mexicain
pour proposer un potager en permaculture
dans un cadre qui a une signification de
tenter cette eau rouge c'était pour
montrer que ben voilà le jardin vient se
construire sur
toutes les guerres toute la pollution
etc que génère les hommes sur le monde
et qui va venir par son action vertueuse
pas purifier l'eau ramener du vivant là
où tout était mort tout était capsciné
chaque équipe de concepteurs venus du
monde entier dis près de 15000 euros
financés par le domaine pour créer son
jardin tous les projets comme ceux de
Bruno et Louise avaient été sélectionnés
par un jury en novembre dernier les
assets alliance de du respect du sujet
de la proposition de solution parce que
la résilience est de faire une
difficulté une force la difficulté c'est
le réchauffement climatique et toutes
les
questions liées à l'eau par exemple et
en même temps ce sont des jardins qui
sont beaux qui ont des mises en scènes
des scénarios très intéressants le
festival est à visiter jusqu'au 5
novembre les plantes seront ensuite
récupérées pour être réutilisés ailleurs
sur le domaine et laisser la place à
d'autres jardins l'année prochaine